Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble and fully Self-Awakened One.
so this evening i thought we'd get back to basics a little bit and just look at this word dukkha get my tablet properly here we go uh the first thing is just to catch a little bit of the etymology of it supposedly according to winthrop sergeant
The ancient Aryans who brought the Sanskrit language to India were a nomadic horse- and cattle-breeding people who travelled in horse- and ox-drawn vehicles.
Su- and du- are prefixes indicating good and bad.
The word ka- in later Sanskrit comes to mean sky, ether or space, but was originally just a hole, particularly of an axle.
and so sukha meant having a good axle hole and dukkha meant having a poor one so that gives you some indication as to his roots but before we go into dukkha and its uh crucial place in the buddhist teachings uh just as a general understanding about isms about religions
uh all the abrahamic religions have a god a supernatural being who uh you know punishes punishes you if you do something wrong and gives you lots of ice cream if you do something right uh this uh this sort of god as you know has created enormous problems for the western civilization depending on which side god was on
the east is different there's no such personal god in hinduism and all that around good and bad moral behavior is taken god is taken care of by the law of karma as it is in buddhism and jainism but the hinduism came to uh teach more of brahman who was an impersonal god
But in terms of the other main religions, Taoism, Jainism and Buddhism, they are simply no God.
They are non-theistic.
So the Buddha then, like these other two religions, Jainism and Taoism, it all depends on the individual human being.
We create our own worlds.
We have to get out of the mess.
And once we're out of the mess,
we are in a state of purity and happiness.
Now, that word, bruka, is such a wide meaning that there's no one English word can do it.
And it was originally translated as suffering, but that's far too heavy, you might say.
Unsatisfactoriness and then even stress, for those of you who know the work of Ajahn Thanissaro.
Now, just as these religions have a grounding in supernatural being, which cannot be proven, although they say it can be, you'll also find that in the humanistic religions or the secular religions of liberalism,
communism national socialism in its worst form nazism and now a tweaked form of liberalism as neoliberalism and all of these all have a premise and we know for instance in neoliberalism everything is to be controlled and guided by the market the governments and unions all have to get out of the way the market knows best and we all know where that's taken us
So once a premise is proven to be untrue or leading to disaster, then the whole fabric, the whole architecture of that belief disappears.
So now the Buddha grounds himself on something which simply cannot be denied, dukkha.
And the first discourse is around this word dukkha.
And this is what he says at the beginning of it.
There are two extremes should not be followed by one who has gone forth into homelessness.
We can take homelessness to mean anybody on the spiritual path.
What two?
The pursuit of sensual happiness in sensual pleasures, which is low, vulgar, the way of worldlings, ignoble, unbeneficial.
And the pursuit of self-mortification, which is painful, ignoble, unbeneficial.
Without veering towards either of these two extremes, the tathāgata, that's what he called himself, it translates badly as such gone, it's basically the transcendent one, has awakened to the middle way, which gives rise to vision, gives rise to knowledge, which leads to peace, to direct knowledge, to enlightenment, to nibbāna.
So the first one is about
indulgence, which is that desire and attachment.
And the second one is really blaming the body for all the desires we have.
So if I didn't have a tongue, if I didn't have the sense of taste, I'd have no problem with food.
that's a mistake that uh perhaps was made by the james who said who felt that the body itself the material of the body was cut the karmic result of bad actions now in that discourse he delineates the truth he first of all states clearly that there is the truth of dukkha
and we'll come to exactly how he defines that later then he points to the second which is the cause of dukkha which of course lies in that craving and the third is the cessation of dukkha dukkha is completely overcome by letting go of that craving and attachment and then there's a path of course leading to the cessation of suffering a cessation of dukkha suffering uh the eightfold path
And then he goes on to say what we should do about this dukkha.
So this is the noble truth of suffering.
I'll use the word dukkha.
The noble truth of suffering is to be fully understood.
The noble truth of dukkha has been fully understood.
So he's talking about himself now.
Then he talks about the origin of dukkha.
The noble truth of the origin of dukkha is to be abandoned.
That cause of dukkha is eventually to be abandoned.
And then he states of himself the origin of dukkha has been abandoned.
In the third one he says there is a noble truth of the cessation, the complete eradication of dukkha.
the noble truth of the sensation of dukkha is to be realized so this is something that is to be personally experienced that's the liberation from suffering and the noble truth of dukkha has been realized by himself this discourse was given to his five companions remember he'd left them
he had then gone on his own and this and finally found the enlightenment or became should we say awakened and when he came back this is the talk that he gave to them and this is of course a formalized talk but it gives us some idea of what that original conversation was about this is what the blessed one said and being pleased the group of five delighted in the blessed one's statement
And while this discourse is being spoken, there arose in the Venerable Kandanya the dust-free, stainless vision of the Dhamma.
Whatever is subject to arising is all subject to ceasing.
Then the Buddha expressed this heartfelt sentiment.
Kandanya has really understood.
And that's how Venerable Kandanya became known as
kandanya who understands or anya kandanya so that's the first definition of dukkha yeah dukkha later on becomes slightly more uh refined in the sense of being one of the three characteristics of existence and that's these are what we're investigating in our vipassana so it's uh anicha the the quality of impermanence
Knowing impermanence, seeing impermanence, begins to understand why holding on to anything pleasant leads to suffering, because everything, of course, disappears.
Impermanence also leads us to understand anatta, not self, because the self is supposed to be eternal, immortal.
so now we come to the core aspects of dukkha and this is the most general explanation that he gives first of all there's ordinary suffering so the dukkha dukkha right so that first dukkha refers to all the natural suffering and displeasure that we get in life um
and the dukkha that he's referring to which we get rid of is of course the relationship we have of wanting and not wanting reactivity so all our reactions based upon the idea of a self seeking to make this world a pleasant place for itself always manipulating the world to make a pleasant place of itself wanting not wanting that's the first form of dukkha
The next form is caused by, as we just mentioned, viparinamadukkha, change.
So even pleasant experiences are to be looked upon as impermanent and very foolish to hang on to them.
So when we have a party, we always want another one just like it.
And of course, it never turns out the way we want it.
And finally, there's the suffering due to conditionality, sankharadukkha.
so sankara is conditionality but it's also to do with compoundedness everything is made up of bits and pieces that constitute an object or rather that the human being sees as an object so we ourselves we experience ourselves as whole complete entire and yet when we actually you know investigate ourselves
You know, we're just a mass of cells or a mass, bodily speaking, a mass of cells or just chemicals or just subatomic energy.
And the mind is just this constant flow of thinking, imagining, emotionals.
So that means that it has that this body, this self doesn't have a permanent essence.
That's the important thing.
and not seeing that leads us into this delusion which is the fundamental cause of our suffering finally uh he sums it all up in in a sense so this is his definition of dukkha birth is dukkha aging is dukkha illness is dukkha and death is dukkha
sorrow lamentation pain grief and despair are dukkha association with the unloved is dukkha separation from the loved is dukkha not getting what one wants is dukkha in conclusion the five clinging aggregates the khandhas are dukkha so that final sentence
the clinging aggregates so they remember that those are the body itself all our feelings physical and emotional in the body all our perceptions and then these sankara so this is where we come in because through an act of will we've created these volitional conditionings habits which are conditioned and conditioning and our job as meditators
is to perceive this whole process of how we create suffering and it is perceiving the process that is the process of liberation okay uh the final candle was consciousness by the way so i can only hope that this little um uh
talk on dukkha will be of some benefit and that you will by your personal and complete devotion to the practice liberate yourself from all suffering sooner rather than later